You can do anything!
Paint a masterpiece in a minute,
learn every language in an hour,
build a multi-billion dollar
company overnight,
and rule the world by tomorrow!
Or is it because you're not using
your brain at its full potential?
This is 'What If,'
and here's what your brain
would be like at full capacity.
The brain, to say the least,
is very complex.
We've studied it for centuries, and we're
still learning more of its secrets today.
But be careful! The search for facts
can sometimes lead to fiction.
Brain size relates more to proportion
than it does to intelligence.
For example, here's your brain
next to a whale's.
Your brain is smaller than a whale's
because your body is smaller.
However, your brain is structured in a way
that enables you to survive, and succeed.
We've seen what really
smart people can do.
They inspire us through
art, music, and literature;
they change the odds in sports;
they come up with tools
to make our lives easier;
and they help organize society as a whole
to make us all more powerful
for better or for worse.
With access to your brain's
full capacity, you're limitless.
So what do you do?
First things first, you finally
get to solve the Rubik's cube
that's been collecting dust on your shelf.
Call up your smartest friend, and
challenge them to a game of chess.
Checkmate in two moves.
When you're done being a smarty pants,
you'll be looking for a real challenge.
Since, being smart means that
you won't be as stimulated
by the things that keep
us simpletons happy...
When you're limitless,
you don't have to choose.
"Picasso was overrated!"
"Sorry I'm late, I was up
all night curing cancer!"
"...so I thought, well why not? And that's
how the time traveling toilet came to be!"
Okay, back up.
What happens to your body when
you're dedicating all your brain's energy
to a creation, a cure, or a patent?
Your lungs breathing,
your heart beating,
your food digesting,
and your blood circulating
that's all your brain.
Even if you could access 100% of
your brain's capacity, you couldn't use it.
You would be limited by
your body's survival needs.
Remember when we asked,
The 10% thing is a myth; and it
probably comes from a simple confusion.
Your brain is 10% neurons,
and 90% glial cells.
There are different types of neurons
that take care of different functions,
but in general, your neurons enable you
to process and transmit information,
while your glial cells surround your neurons,
providing them with support and insulation.
Your brain has just as many
neurons as Albert Einstein's did!
Maintain healthy habits;
that's the smart thing to do!
And, of course, it's a no brainer!